Sorry, guys.
Oh, wait.
This is my recording set.
God damn it.
I can't keep... God.
Okay.
Sorry.
Let me restart that.
Sorry, guys.
I was like, why am I so quiet?
I was like, oh, shit.
I'm still... I'm on my recording... recording settings again.
And I'm... I'm being very sleepy.
I can't.
Yeah, I took a nap again today because for the first time, for the first time, I actually slept late at, like, 4 a.m.
last night or today.
Because yesterday, I also napped.
So I'm creating a really bad cycle right now because it's really bad because this fucker right next to me right now likes to wake up at 6 to 7 in the morning for food time.
And he's been very, very, very demanding.
I've sent emails to two different trainers and have yet to receive a response.
So...
That's great.
So I didn't get a lot of sleep today.
So that's why I took another nap, even though I know it's a very bad idea to take a nap and wake up right before stream because I get even more extra EP before stream.
My brain takes a while.
My brain takes a while to, like, wake up.
There's also apparently a dog.
I think someone got a new dog and he's been, like, a little yapper as well and he's been, like, barking outside his door and dad is like, who the fuck is that guy?
I want to fight him.
So, he's been barking as well outside my door because that little guy's creating a fucking loop.
So, um, no, I could tell from the yelps, I could tell from the yelps that it is, like, goddamn Poodle Terrier.
Like, you can tell exactly how, like, what kind of breeds they are depending on their barks and, like, I know what a Poodle Terrier bark is.
Okay, so, by the way, it's actually pretty funny because, like, remember when I was telling you guys how I was looking up, my manager gave this crazy idea where it's, like, high risk, high reward where, like, maybe I should get two dogs.
Maybe I should get another dog so they could, like, so, like, maybe dad will stop bothering me and stop barking at me if he has, like, another friend.
And the risk is that maybe the risk would be those two working together to fuck me over.
But, like, I have to tell you guys that I was looking at adoption websites, like, in my city, and, like, literally, there are no wiener dogs.
Because I told you guys, like, there's no way someone would put a wiener dog up for adoption because they're, despite them being, like, pieces of shit.
They are purebreds and, um, they're very, very expensive dog breeds because, like, um, yeah, they are very expensive.
So, no one would, like, put them in a pound because of how, uh, how valued they are.
But, you know what I did see on the adoption websites?
A lot of fucking poodle terriers.
I swear to God.
It was, like, it was, like, 30% chihuahuas, 30%, uh, pit bulls, and then 30% poodle terriers.
And then when I looked up dachshunds, it was, like, they were, like, mixed with other dog breeds.
Like, they're, like, yeah, this is, like, a chihuahua, a dachshund.
I was, like, no, I don't want, like, two little shits mixed together because then it produces, like, an even worse...
An even worse attitude slash personality.
Um...
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki, I love your summer outfit.
It kind of reminds me of Ace Ventura a bit.
But today, also today, I found Starscream and Megatron Yaoi doujin.
I could not read because it's Japanese.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That is a wild super chat.
But, like, who the fuck reads the doujins for...
Who the fuck reads doujins for the text?
And the story.
You, we all know.
I know you all read doujins for the artwork.
Like, who the fuck cares about what the text says?
Like...
The pod.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, no.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Doki.
Had a great time.
I've walked out and seen your panel.
Uh, will you ever confirm the night of question?
Uh, okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
Not missing now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Today is my first birthday.
It's a dragon.
Can I get a happy birthday from my Oshi?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Missing.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
All right.
So, that update.
There's actually a lot of dad updates that's been happening.
But I'm going to, like, space these stories out.
I'm going to run out of dad updates.
Because, like, how many stories can I say when he's, like, at the dog park?
Or, like, how many new things can possibly happen?
Um...
Anyway.
Oh, man.
I'm trying to figure out which one to give you guys.
Because I wrote down all the...
I write down, like, all these updates and stuff when I'm, like, out, like, on my phone.
So I don't forget.
Uh...
Okay.
All right.
I'll tell you guys the dad up the ball incident.
Okay.
So, um...
Yesterday.
This is from yesterday, too.
Uh...
Yesterday, um...
I've started bringing his ball with me to the dog park.
Because, like, um...
I was tired of him trying to steal other dogs' balls.
And then also, like, I needed him to, like, get his energy down more.
Because he has been having way too much energy.
I think it's the food.
I think the wet dog food has been giving him too much energy.
Um...
Because he used to be, like, such a calm boy.
Like, he used to be, like, more of a lazy dog.
But nowadays, he has, like, way too much energy.
And I think it's the wet dog food.
Um...
I even, like, asked the vet if I could, like, swap it back to, like, dry food.
Like, kibble.
And my vet said that it is possible.
I just need to put...
Uh...
I just need to put, like, water...
Um...
Water into the dry food.
So that he'll get, like, moisture and stuff.
Um...
For his kidneys.
So, like, I'm planning on doing that, uh...
Next week.
Because I still have a lot of wet dog food left.
So, um...
And, like, they're very expensive.
They cost me, like, a hundred dollars for two weeks.
So, like, it's...
Because, you know, I'm sure it tastes a lot better.
Uh...
Yeah.
Anyway.
No!
He will be so...
He'll forget.
He'll forget about it.
He'll live.
Anyway.
So, um...
So, I've been trying to bring his ball with me down at the dog park.
So he won't steal other people's balls.
And so...
And then, like, we could play fetch and stuff.
So he'll, like...
Uh...
He'll, like, waste his energy more.
So, I went downstairs and, like, headed to the dog park with his ball.
And, you know, I decided.
I was like, alright.
It's time to play fetch time.
It's fetch time.
And then, um...
I threw the ball.
And at first, like, the first two throws, it was alright.
He's like, yippee!
Fetch time!
And then another dog...
Twoking it...
Came in.
And then stole his ball.
And...
And, obviously, he was not happy about that.
He was very, very mad.
But, like, he couldn't do anything about it.
Because this dog was, like, bigger than him.
He was, like...
It was, like, an actual poodle.
It wasn't...
Like, actually, no.
He was, like, the big poodle terriers.
Not, like, poodle poodle.
But they were, like, the big poodle terriers.
Not the small poodle terriers.
It's always poodle terriers.
Anyway!
So...
The ones that are, like, mostly legs.
You know?
Like...
So...
So that was a problem.
And then, so...
The owner was, like...
Oh, okay.
Oh, don't worry.
I brought my own ball, too.
Like, in case this happens.
So then, like...
He threw his own ball.
And then...
Dad stole that one.
Because he was, like...
You're gonna steal my ball?
I'm gonna steal your ball.
You take mine.
I take yours.
And then...
It was a huge issue.
Because...
He wouldn't let go.
This was...
The first time...
He's never let go of a ball before.
Because he always wants to play fetch.
So every time I just, like...
You know...
I...
Put my hand down.
And go, what ball?
And then he'll, like...
Give me the ball.
But for the first time...
He refused to let go.
And, like...
I was like, okay...
Maybe this is just a phase.
Maybe he's just, like...
Incredibly paranoid that, like...
Another dog is gonna steal at this again.
So he, like...
Didn't wanna, like...
Let go.
Because he was like...
My ball's keep getting stolen!
This ball stays in my mouth!
So...
Because I was, like...
I was, like...
Trying to...
You know...
I can't pull too hard.
Because it's back.
So I was just like...
Come on!
And then I just, like...
Pulled it a little bit.
He's like...
No!
Like...
And he was just, like...
He was just, like...
Fighting hard on that ball.
I was like...
No!
And pulling it back.
I was like...
This is mine!
And then...
So...
Um...
I let him, like...
You know...
Think about it.
For, like...
Ten minutes.
But then the other...
The owner had to go.
And he was, like...
Hey...
Can we, like...
You know...
Trade balls?
Like...
I got your ball back.
I was, like...
Oh, yeah.
No.
No problem.
Yeah.
I think it'll be fine.
And so, like, I picked him up and then I tried, you know, pulling the ball, but he, like, wouldn't let go.
He was like, no!
I was like, and then the owner, like, gave me his ball back.
I was like, look, look, Dad, I've got your ball here.
Come on, let go of the other one.
And he's like, come on!
He's like, no!
And he still was, like, holding on to it.
I literally had him in my arms.
I sat down on the bench just trying to pull the ball out and trying to, like, you know, I was trying to pull the ball out, but it was, like, literally locked into his jaw.
And I was like, do you see this?
Here's your ball.
Do you see this?
This is your ball.
And he's like, no!
Like, he never let go.
And then, so then the other owner was like, oh, well, um, you can, like, you know, whenever we see each other again, like, I don't know, we see each other dog part a lot, just, you could just, yeah, give it back to us whenever, like, you're on your walk.
I was like, I'm so sorry.
He, he's, he would, he, he's used to, he, he's always gives the ball back.
Like, I don't know why he doesn't want to today.
I'm so sorry.
Like, he's never done that before.
He was like, he would always, like, play fetch with me, because I'd be like, pop-ball, and he'll, like, drop the ball in my hand or on the floor.
But this time, he, like, refused to let go.
And I think he's just extremely paranoid about, like, other dogs trying to steal his ball now.
And then, so, they left, and then, and then he was still, like, he still had it in his, like, he still had it in his mouth.
And then, I swear to God, okay, so, like, all the dogs left at that point, because I was just like, okay, I'm just gonna wait, because I'm waiting for him to poop.
I'm not fucking, the last time I, like, went back to, uh, my apartment without him pooping, because he took to a dog, he, like, pooped in the hallway.
So, I've just been, like, waiting.
I think he was, like, really paranoid.
He's like, if I let go of this ball, someone's gonna steal it.
So I'm gonna wait until every dog is gone until I go poop.
And...
So, all the dogs are gone from the dog park.
It's, like, 9 p... I think it's, like, 10 p.m.
or some shit.
And then, um, finally, he pooped.
And then, and he, like, he, like, he was holding onto the ball while pooping.
And then he dropped it.
And then I, obviously, you know, I have to pick it up.
And then I, like, went over to pick up.
And he instantly, like...
Oh, my God.
It's so gross.
He, like, mid-pooped, like...
Like, not unsqu... He was still squatting.
But he, like, shuffled in his squat to, like, pick up the ball.
I'm gonna steal your poop.
Oh, my God.
I'm not gonna steal your ball.
Oh, my... I'm gonna fucking pick up the poop so I can throw it.
I was like, Dad, please.
I'm not gonna steal your ball.
That is so disgusting.
Like, I was just like, oh, my God.
It was still... It was so bad.
I was just like, bro, it's still hanging.
Why did you do that, bro?
I... Oh, my God.
Um... And then after... After, uh...
After... After we were done with, you know, at the dog park, he still didn't let go.
The only time he ever let go of the ball was when we were back in our apartment.
Like, I swear to God, he, like, held onto that ball all the way till we were back to the apartment.
He did not let go.
I was like, Jesus Christ, Dad.
Just like, oh.
And then, I forgot to tell this, but at one point, he, like, walked to the door and was like, I want to go.
Like, he tried to demand me to leave because he was like, I don't want anyone to steal this ball.
I want to go home now.
I'm like, come on.
Dad, no.
No, come back.
I have to walk to the door and then, like, body block the door and be like, come on.
Go.
We're not going home.
Come on.
He was so fucking paranoid.
He was like, no, they're going to steal it.
Like, now they stole my ball.
Not so funny.
Now when I have your ball.
I got to put it somewhere safe.
I got to bring it home now.
So, yeah.
Now I have an extra ball that I have to, like, bring back every time I go to the dog park in case I see the poodle owner again.
So I can return this stupid fucking ball.
Oh.
He's so goddamn paranoid now.
All right.
Anyway, I hope SoundGuy is here because I forgot to save the sound settings for Halo.
So we're going to have to figure that out together.
Because I remember this game is terribly mixed, right?
It's terribly mixed for audio.
So it's going to be a fun time, SoundGuy.
All right.
Time to boot it up.
Anyway.
That is yesterday's dad update.
Today there's another dad update.
Also, ball related.
You know, I can, you know, fuck, I'll slip it in because this is a fast story.
So today, you know, this time, this time I brought treats with me.
Every day I get a little smarter.
I don't have to fucking deal with this dog.
But today, I also, I also, I brought a ball and treats.
So in case he tries to steal another ball, I can bring out the treats so that I can bring out the treats and stuff.
So he could, you know, I'd be like, hey, here's some treats so he could let go of the ball.
So this is a quick dad update for today.
I'll explain more tomorrow or something.
But basically, at one point, we saw another giant Poodle Terrier.
It's literally the same dog breed, but this time he's black instead of brown.
Because then the ball he stole was from a brown dog.
Um, and then this one is, it's the same, it's literally the same breed.
Like, they look the same, except for the colors.
So this time, it's literally the same dog breed.
The giant Poodle Terriers.
Um, they're three times the size of him.
But this time he's black.
Um, but anyway, that, that one also tried to steal his ball.
Um, but, um, um, the thing is, um, um, he tries to bring the ball back to, back to the owner.
And then the owner would give me back his ball.
And the, but, but like, that dog kept trying to steal his ball.
Uh, well, to be fair, that was the ball he stole.
I literally brought back down, like, the, the ball he stole from the other owner.
Um, just in case I see him again.
Because I didn't want to bring two balls down with me.
Um, anyway.
So, uh, at one point, dad got really fucking annoyed by this Poodle Terrier stalking him for the ball.
Uh, yes, I have, I have to.
Because, like, I don't want to bring the two balls down with me.
It's efficient.
Uh, okay, I don't have to.
I'm just lazy.
Anyway.
So, he, like, at one point, he got really fucking annoyed at this other Poodle Terrier trying to steal his ball.
That he, like, went to the owner.
And, like, went behind her.
Like, behind her legs.
And be like, you deal with this.
Train your dog better.
He, like, he, like, held on to the ball and just went to the other owner.
And it's like, you should train him better.
Stop letting him try to steal my ball.
Control him.
Control your dog.
Like, he literally went behind the dog owner.
Like, just like, like, he looked at the dog owner.
He's like, yeah.
Train him better.
Teach him some matters.
And then when the other Poototero came over and she was like, scolding him, he like was behind her legs like, yeah, that's right.
He's like, yeah, that's right.
You deserve this.
Think before you try to steal my ball.
I'll go back to your owner again if you do that again.
He's like, do better.
I was just like, Jesus Christ, you're no better.
You are no better, Dad.
Um...
Netverse, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Angi, let me tell you, Angi I am since my ball was stolen.
There's over 1.1 miles of fuzz on this tennis ball.
And if the word Angi was on each micron of fuzz, it wouldn't be how Angi I feel for ball feed.
He's dead, probably.
Thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
Alright.
Time to play some Hello.
Okay.
Let me log in real quick.
Okay, we gotta listen to this song because it's iconic.
Ohhhh...
It's the...
It's the Halo song.
All the...
Me and the boys...
Ohhhh...
Doing the Halo chant.
Time to sing it.
Yeah, this is what happens to the men's bathroom.
Um...
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
He went to the manager.
He's such a Karen.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Bum bum.
Campaign...
Hey...
Wait, no.
Not Halo Reach.
Alright, resume.
I remember where I'm at.
Oh yeah, we're at a new mission.
Assault in the controller room.
I don't know how many missions I'm gonna do today.
I'm definitely not finishing it today.
But like...
Wait, do I have a pistol?
Oh my god, I do.
Wait, what?
Why am I here?
Why am I like right here?
Where...
Where's my backup?
Like why am I literally...
Why am I like in...
Oh my god!
What?
What is this checkpoint?
I'm literally right here!
What the fuck is this?
Oh my god.
What is this checkpoint?
Why am I like right in the thick of things?
I...
Where are my team?
Oh my god.
This is bad.
Okay.
This is so bad for me.
Oh my god.
Please, please don't hit me.
Just hit zero shots.
Hit zero shots.
I beg of you.
I'm literally one HP.
I...
Alright.
It's fine.
Okay.
We're okay now.
Holy shit!
What kind of checkpoint was that?
That was the most bullshit checkpoint ever!
It goes...
There was zero cover!
Alright.
I'm not okay.
I like literally went straight into hell.
The...
...
Here it is!
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh, ward ward.
No!
Nononononononononon...
Oh...
Oh my god, are you fucking kidding me!
Okay!
Okay.
This is good.
Alright, this is fine.
One HP in a dream.
Okay.
No!
Why are you not BMP?
Oh, nice checkpoint.
Alright, it's fine.
Okay.
It's okay.
I just gotta recharge my shield.
Oh my god.
A quick track will start appraising messages.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Where am I appraised?
Okay.
Here we go.
Now I can kill him.
And look at that one guy.
He's like, oh, hey guys.
What's going on?
He's just like, hey, where's Jerry?
Did he die?
Alright.
There's one guy to my left.
Oh, please tell me there's heals somewhere.
Oh, hey.
There's a...
Wait.
You're not... Oh, can I just go over there?
There's an ostrich over there.
Oh my god.
Is that...
What are you doing here?
You can't be a hero.
You're just a little grunt.
You're not a hero.
Get out of here.
That's right.
You're barely doing any damage.
You're not a lead.
Alright.
It's fine.
What is this?
Jesus Christ.
It's always so bright.
It's so weird seeing how bright it is compared to like...
Uh...
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Okay.
Wait.
I got this.
Ugh.
Come on!
Why are my legs so short, John Halo?
Oh my god.
I am crouch jumping.
I played G-Bod.
I swear...
I swear to god.
I swear to...
Oh my god.
There we go.
I swear to god I was crouch jumping.
Alright.
It's just...
Not me!
I... There is no...
You cannot trick me.
There is no such thing as grenade jump.
You can't fucking get me again.
There's like medkits nearby.
Oh my god.
I need...
I need medkits.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
The Covenant presence here is stronger than I anticipated.
They seem to have the entire region secured.
Okay.
I swear to god.
Do I have checkpoints?
It's legit.
Alright.
I swear to god.
Wait.
Is there...
Is there any heals here?
Is there any...
Before...
Before I do it...
Are...
Are there any...
Any heals?
You have no...
That's why I'm asking if there's heals!
I...
I need to make sure you're not...
You're not gaslighting me.
Alright.
Here we go.
I don't think they see those.
We're actually going in with one HP and a dream right now.
Hello everybody.
Okay.
Wait.
I'm just like wondering if I like...
Rebinded anything.
The weather patterns here seem natural, not artificial.
I wonder if the ring's environment systems are malfunctioning.
Or if the designer...
Oh, okay.
It's so cute.
They're sleeping.
Whoops.
Sorry.
He woke up.
Oh shit!
Oh!
They...
No!
Fuck!
This is Cortana.
Hold position.
We're on our way.
Okay, it's fine.
Roger this.
Make it quick.
It's fine.
I have this.
I...
It was...
It was not fine.
What if the ring's environment systems are malfunctioning?
Or if the designer didn't want to...
It was not fine.
Guys, it was not fine.
It's fine now.
It should be fine now.
Please, please.
No!
Okay, this time.
I can self this.
I don't understand.
How did he wake up so fast?
I wonder if the ring's environment systems are malfunctioning.
Like how does he know?
Oh, that's how he knows.
It's okay.
He can't know a second time.
I got this.
And I'm gonna do something like this.
And I'll be like...
And then I'm gonna run to this one.
And then I'm gonna shoot him from here.
Ha ha ha ha!
Stupid!
He hit a wall!
That's fucking right.
And then...
And then I'm gonna...
No!
I took too long!
I...
I took too long to get out!
With a pistol!
But it's such a tiny gun!
Wait.
Oh, there's less people now.
I wonder if the ring's environment systems are malfunctioning.
I think the game feels sorry for me.
Why is there less people?
What is there?
Oh, no.
He...
Wait.
What?
No!
They just woke up and I got confused!
Okay.
This is fine.
Alright, here we go.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Get out!
Get out of here!
This is fucked up.
What hit me?!
Oh my god!
Oh!
I'm stuck in a fucking loop!
You're seeing natural, not artificial.
I wonder if the ring's environment systems are malfunctioning.
Oh my god!
Stop!
Okay, here we go.
What the fuck you were sleeping?!
Who got onto this one?!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
Get out of here!
There!
You fucker.
I...
Okay.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, I got covered.
Get out of here!
Oh my god, it's burning.
There we go.
Okay.
The pistol was all I need.
Alright, now I can use this for real.
There we go.
Okay, now I can't.
He's like blocking it.
Alright, there we go.
I'm not running.
We don't run here.
We gotta make sure they're all dead.
We gotta get rid of all the aliens.
What the fuck?
What's shot me?
Oh my god, he's down here.
Oh, he's shooting me from below.
Okay.
It's fine.
Wait, it's not fine?
Where is he?
Where the fuck is he?
Okay, I gotta really...
Alright.
Give me your gun.
No, not this gun!
Okay.
Oh my god, they're all the needlers.
Oh my god, I hate this.
I'm so far away.
Okay, I need this gun.
I gotta make sure I don't die from this guy from below me.
From underground.
You still have shields?
Yeah, you do.
Yeah, you fucking do.
Little bitch.
Shit.
That's fucking right.
I'm pretty sure I got all the shields out.
Alright, get over here.
Come on.
Where are you?
Oh shit!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Okay, I almost thought I was gonna fall down.
Wait, where did he go?
He disappeared.
He actually disappeared.
Where did he go?
Did I kill him?
He just fell off?
Oh, that sucks.
I thought he had like two more years in him.
Oh my god.
OH SHIT!
Okay, it's fine.
Oh my god, it's not fine.
I have to be so careful because of how low HP I am.
That sucks, buddy.
Falling off like that.
Oh, I don't have a lot of pistol ammo left.
It's fine.
Hello?
God damn it.
I got distracted by this guy.
Okay, I need to make sure every ammo counts.
Oh my god, he reminds me of Tiny Chef.
Wait!
He sounds just like Tiny Chef!
Are you serious?
I said I need to make sure every bullet counts.
And I missed?
Okay, there we go.
He won a blimmy.
WOOOOO!
No!
No no no no no no no no no!
No no no no no no no no!
Oh, okay...
I think we're okay.
I...
I don't have much to give.
I don't have much to...
Oh, he's dead!
Oh my god, he's dead.
Okay.
I didn't think he would die that fast.
Thank God.
Oh, thank God.
I was gonna send that over there.
Yeah, I cannot be.
I do not trust myself to go forward.
Cuz I don't need the kneeler.
Look at that, I survived.
Look at that.
One hit, one kill.
Oh, yes, the checkpoint when I'm one HP.
I love it.
You think he knows?
Guys, I don't think he knows.
Oh, no.
Where is he?
Oh, yeah, nice.
Headshot.
Okay, nice.
We got a better gun.
Okay, we got a better gun, guys.
We're okay now.
We're okay.
Everything is okay.
Calculated, guys.
Very calculated.
Also, sound guy.
Oh, nice.
Heal.
Heals.
Oh, I can be less scared now.
JK, I'm always scared.
I'm always paranoid.
I hear him.
But how's the sound so far, sound guy?
Where are they?
Oh, there he is.
I was like, where is this real guy?
I see him.
Oh.
No.
It's okay.
I'm ready with the backshots.
I've been practicing in Elden Ring.
I told you.
Every game there's backshots.
I'm becoming a master backshotter.
Look at that.
I'm a professional now.
There we go.
That's right.
It's lethal.
Oh.
Somebody stop it!
Oh, we're safe.
Mirage will take us out.
Things are fine, but the game is right under your level and big fights.
Okay.
That's good.
I don't know if that's good, actually.
Alright, here I go.
That's right.
And they don't stop coming.
They heard the rumors.
They're like, there's no way.
Alright.
Ooh.
This is a long ass elevator.
Oh my god.
What a waste of...
Space.
Okay.
It was worth it.
Poink.
It was all a very bad dream, guys.
It was all...
It was all a very bad dream.
Wow.
It's like it never...
Never happened.
Oh, he has shields.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh my god.
Alright, that's fine.
I wanted to kill them all anyway.
Oh wait.
I need...
This one.
I'm running out of ammo.
Alright, where is he?
There we go.
It just wasn't worth it.
I don't...
I don't think I should waste my ammo for these guys.
Do I go down here?
Aw.
Wait.
That bulletproof glass?
When did they invent bulletproof glass?
Alright.
I guess we go that way.
Yeah.
Go this way.
Oh.
There's something over here.
Aw.
I wanted to shoot through that glass.
We have to go this way anyway.
Okay.
Oops.
Why is it sometimes...
Is it because I get hit?
If I get hit, like...
Oh!
Oh my god.
Please, please, please, please.
I do not want to lose heals here.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Alright.
Oh!
When I get hit, it, like, de-scopes.
Okay.
I was gonna say, like...
Why does it unscope myself?
Is he sleeping?
Oh, they're sleeping forever.
Technically, they are sleeping.
It's just...
Maybe it's...
I sleep forever.
I'm on hard difficulty.
And it's not that hard.
Oh!
Over here?
Uh...
I guess over here.
Did I come from here?
No.
The arrows are pointing away.
Right?
Yeah.
The arrows are pointing...
Oh yeah!
I'm outside!
Oh my god!
Okay.
That's awkward.
Oh, hey!
They're my people!
Okay.
I'm just gonna use this.
It doesn't look like yours fall off.
For this.
Yeah.
What?!
What shot me?!
Oh!
These guys.
Can I destroy that?
Is that possible?
Can I destroy that or no?
I can't tell.
Yeah?
Okay.
I'm just gonna shimmy a little.
I'm okay, though.
I think my...
I think the army's dead.
No, they're still alive.
Okay.
Maybe I should save them.
I'm gonna go over and save them real quick.
Uh-oh.
I think that's a good idea.
There we go.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm a hero!
Don't fight this thing alone!
Oh.
What?!
I...
Oh, yeah.
I need tissues right now.
I ran up.
I ran up tissues.
I'm freaking sick.
I don't know how the fuck I died there.
Like, I literally...
I just exploded!
What killed me?!
I got hit in the back by a car?!
Did anyone get their license plate?!
Oh, that's...
Yeah, I...
I hear the gunshots.
Oh, that's awkward.
That's...
Ooh...
I hear...
Ooh, that's awkward.
Whoa...
Whoopsie!
Okay, this is a...
Oops...
This is a waste.
Can I lead this?
No.
Wait, I can't.
God damn it.
I thought I could lead it.
Wait, there's a goat?
There's a goat somewhere?
Bro, it's so hard to see where's the ghosts.
Cause they're all...
We're like in the snow.
How the fuck am I supposed to know where they are?
Okay, maybe I can...
Oh, it would be so awkward if I actually put the marine there.
That would be so awkward.
Oh my god, I can't lead my fucking shot for the life of me.
There you go.
There we go.
He's dead.
Oh, it's a vehicle!
Oh!
I thought you meant like an actual...
Like, the invisible guys are called ghosts.
I thought that's what you meant.
Alright.
These guys I'm gonna use.
Use this.
Just cause I can't lead my shots here.
Oh no.
There you go.
My hand hurt.
Okay, there you go.
Nice.
Oh my god, marine...
Marines are still alive!
Good for them.
Oh my god, there's still so many.
What are you guys doing?
Okay, I'm gonna put this over here for these guys.
I hope that this hits him.
Alright.
I see you!
Oh shit!
Wait, that hit me!
Boy, I didn't see you.
Hello?
Is he dead?
I think he's dead.
Alright, we can go back.
Don't worry, you're alive.
Oh, wait.
Don't worry, you're...
Okay, thank god.
Thank god.
Okay, you're alive.
It's alright.
Oh, wait!
Oh, thank god all of you died!
Now I have a new gun!
Nice.
Oh, but there's only like 22 bullets.
Okay, wait.
Is that this?
Or...
Okay, how many bullets?
Uh, I'll go with a sniper.
A sniper's better.
Okay, that's good.
Since all of you guys are dead, I get to steal all your ammo.
Anybody here?
Oh, there is.
You know what?
It's alright.
I figured this out.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
Let me, uh...
It's so worth it.
They serve their purpose in life.
Oh, shit!
They're...
All your friends are dead.
I don't know what you're talking about.
You can't hide from me!
The baddest...
Badass...
Most badass squad in the marines.
There's...
You're the only survivor.
You're...
Uh...
You're literally the only survivor.
I don't know if I should...
Guys, should I keep the...
Tank?
Uh, sorry.
The rocket launcher?
Or the sniper, guys?
I don't know.
Oh, my chat died.
Whoops.
Let me reload this.
Keep the sniper?
Okay.
Alright.
Let me...
Where is...
Alright.
Whoa!
Wait, did I?
Goddammit.
Okay.
Here we go.
I wanna make sure I got the sniper before I...
Alright.
Let's go.
Yeah, but the pistol's better, though.
Isn't the pistol better?
Come on!
Floor it!
Alright.
Whee!
Wait.
Aww.
It's broken.
I can't use it anymore.
Textures are glitching.
Don't worry, I can fix this.
Whee!
Alright.
Here we go.
Is he almost dead?
Oh, shit.
Come on, you kill him.
You got this, buddy.
I believe in you.
There you go.
I helped.
No witnesses.
Oh, shit.
Oh,
shit.
Bro, buddy.
Don't be a hero.
Get back in here.
Oh, hey.
Oh, we got another buddy.
Oh, my God.
Sergeant!
Sergeant, you're alive?!
Oh, my God.
You're alive!
Is that tank?!
Sergeant Johnson!
Shit.
Okay.
We gotta grab this.
Let's go.
That's right.
There's another one.
Wait.
Okay.
I was gonna say, where's my ammo?
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Sergeant Johnson!
Get on!
Oh, wait.
Did I kill him?
Wait.
What happened to the guy that was...
Ooh.
It's okay.
I had to kill him for Johnson, guys.
Guys, you don't understand.
He had to die so Johnson can...
So Johnson can sit on the tank.
Okay.
Guys, it had to...
Sacrifice had to be made.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh!
I had him another gun.
Okay.
That's actually convenient.
What do you mean almost a man?!
Say that again, Johnson!
To my face!
Do you know what happened to the other Marine that used to be here?
You don't want it to happen to you, Mr. Johnson.
There we go.
Nice.
You know there used to be two Marines here.
Oh, shit.
My shield.
Alright.
Haha.
Where's your shield, bitch?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is this spread, though?
Haha.
What is this?
He takes spread.
It's okay.
Sergeant Johnson's okay, guys.
Goddammit.
Haha.
The fucking clip.
Okay, we got him.
It's fine.
Yeah, they're actual dead dead.
To that one guy.
There was never a one guy.
They're all dead, right?
I'll make sure you destroy that.
Haha.
Okay.
You thought you could hide behind that?
Alright, let's go.
We're fine.
Whoops.
See?
We're fine.
Do I flip, Mr. Johnson?
Can I run him over?
Nice.
More ammo.
Holy shit!
He can't...
OOOOOH!
No!
What the fuck?
The hunkies were just a distraction?
Oh my god, if only... Guys, if only I had someone with a sniper ammo right now.
If only I had someone with a sniper rifle to help me.
Why did they send me alone for this mission?
Why was I sent alone?
Yes!
If only there were more people here!
Oh, he's still alive.
Is he dead yet?
Oh yeah, he's definitely dead.
Alright, I want...
If only I wasn't sent into a one-man mission and had more people...
Oh, whatever, I'm just going to go down here.
Forget about that tank.
Who cares about that tank?
Alright.
Wait, this was a dead end?
What the fuck?
Where did these hunters come from if it was a dead end?
Where do I go?
Oh, there's a button to open the door?
Alright, let's go back down.
I see no button.
Oh, there it is.
Such a tiny button.
Alright.
I'd like a...
I would like a mango smoothie, please.
With some chicken nuggets.
Alright.
Down, I'll go.
What are they going to do?
Destroy my tank?
Ha!
That's fucking right.
That's right.
We can't do anything against this fucker.
I have unlimited ammo.
That's fucking right.
I'm unstoppable.
That's right.
I see you guys over there.
Oh, you think you're so safe.
Oh!
Oh my god.
The ricochet.
What the fuck?
He still lives?
Okay.
This one minion is dodging every single bullet.
This is actually pretty sad.
This is pretty sad.
I can't...
I have unlimited power!
Okay, get out of here.
That's right.
Get closer!
So my bullets can actually hit you!
That's right.
I'm getting closer.
If you won't get closer, I'd get closer.
That's right.
Oh shit, wait.
You're actually hitting me.
Don't worry.
I'm getting closer.
What the fuck?
Okay, I got...
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I got walled.
Guys, I shot a wall accidentally.
I deserve that.
I may or may not have shot a wall.
It's okay.
I learned my lesson.
No more walls for me.
Oh man, I have to shoot...
Are you serious?
Get out of here.
Let me figure out where these guys are.
Okay.
Fuck that one guy in particular though.
I know you're over here.
Come on.
I know you're right over there.
Get out of here.
Who put that wall in?
Who built that wall here just now?
Who did that?
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
There used to be no wall.
All right.
We slowly head up.
There we go.
Oh shit.
I was gonna say, can my tank like accidentally fall?
Would that be fucking hilarious?
From the weight of the tank?
Oh my god.
It's still alive.
I think it's still alive.
Holy shit.
Okay.
It was still alive.
It's fine.
I can shoot it from here.
Bye.
Okay.
That should be where it hits, right?
Right here.
Okay.
No.
There's a wall here.
All right, guys.
I need you to get closer.
Guys, please.
I have a wall here.
I can't...
I can't get to you.
Okay.
Nice.
There we go.
Woo.
Goodbye, Hunter.
Slowly and steady.
There we go.
Wait.
There's so much damage to me.
Why?
I don't like that.
Not my...
Exactly, Willy.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Not my fault someone put a wall there.
Wait, what?
Where'd you get over here?
Okay.
Nice.
Get closer.
Yes.
That's right.
Get closer.
So it can be more efficient.
I know you're here.
What?
Oh, you think that's gonna save you?
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
That's fucking right.
Oh, you got blood on my tire track.
All right.
We go this way now.
Wee.
Okay, there should be a blood in here.
What do you mean, where are the Marines?
They sent me on a one-man mission.
I'm all the Marines they got.
All right.
Down the road I go.
Wee.
Rolling thunder?
Why am I in the middle of a cutscene?
You think these rocks are gonna... Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
Give me a sec.
You think these... Oh my god.
Let me... Okay.
Apparently these rocks are gonna... Are gonna stop me.
You think these rocks are gonna stop me?
That's fucking right.
Get over it.
They will.
So yeah.
I can drive around them.
The nature's not gonna stop me.
Can I destroy this?
Oh shit.
Okay.
That's fine.
Just literally back up.
Surely this car... Yeah.
Sure this guy's gonna be too stupid and drive into me, right?
That's most likely gonna happen.
Alright.
Get over here.
What the fuck are you doing?
Oh, that's just sad.
Guys.
That's fucking sad.
Little buddies.
Get over here.
This is sad.
Get out of here.
This is too sad.
Get out.
That's right.
Can't stop me.
That's fucking right.
What do I do with a ghost when I have a fucking tank.
You know what?
I don't need this shit.
Get this out of here.
Get that junk out of here.
Okay, we gotta get rid of that just in case.
Nice.
Oh, free heals.
Okay, I knew there was some guy over there waiting.
I'll make sure he's out of here.
Oh, what the fuck?
Yeah.
Oh, what?
What sniped me?
Wait, something sniped me.
What?
I got stickied?
Wait, how's there two now?
That's a thing?
Oh my god, bro.
That guy... He is very confident.
But I'm inside the tank.
How did he stickied me?
What the fuck?
How did he get inside?
Did he, like, death-starred it?
He fucking... It was Luke Skywalker.
He death-starred my tank.
That's... Oh my god, he did it again.
He did it again.
That crush deserves a metal.
He actually did it again.
Someone close the cover on my tank.
Please.
Wait, did no one get in the car?
Like, what was that?
Okay, now I know.
I'll never do that again.
Never get close to them.
Never open your heart.
Don't show compassion.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, I knew that rock was gonna kill me.
I fucking knew it.
I'm putting my distance in them now.
That's right.
You can't get close to me now.
That's fucking right.
Oh!
Holy shit.
That guy deserved it.
Oh my god.
Get him out of here.
I don't know how I live.
Oh my god, I live.
That's crazy.
I should not live.
I need to get rid of these.
I don't trust.
Oh my god, that tree tanked entire fucking shot.
Okay, there has to be a health kit right there.
In that pile of bodies.
There has to be a health kit right there.
What do I preemptively fire?
God, I want to grab that health kit.
God, I want to grab it so...
Okay.
Okay, I preemptively shot that hole.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
Open that door again.
That's where I'm looking at you.
Open it again.
Okay, I can grab my health pack.
Okay, nice.
Oh, and there's a rocket launcher too.
Oh, no.
I'll keep this for now.
Why get a rocket launcher when I literally have a fucking tank?
All right.
Do, do, do.
Back to driving.
Is there anybody in that?
Oh, there is.
Whoops.
He's like, oh my god, what the fuck was that?
He's like, you guys saw that?
What was that?
Did I almost die there?
Oh my god, ew.
All right.
Oh, shit.
Is that getting...
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
That was a distraction?
A fucking...
The hunter distraction.
It's like...
John, I'm gonna do it for you.
Okay?
Take the shot, John.
You gotta take the shot.
This is our one and only chance.
Oh my god, my health pack.
My precious health pack.
God.
Okay, so there's always two.
I just didn't think they'd be like right next to each other.
Okay, that...
I know that rock is gonna kill me.
I just know it.
I knew that rock would be the death of me right there.
Okay.
Is it?
Oh, no, it's not.
Okay, thank God.
Okay.
I have to make sure.
I have to make sure I don't die from that rock.
The danger rock.
There we go.
Oh my god, this tank is so nice.
Why don't we have more of this?
Okay, let's try this again.
Okay, that guy one-shot me.
That wasn't my fault.
He literally one-shot me.
Alright.
Oh my god, he lived through all of that?
Okay, I need to like, angle it up here.
Hurry up.
Get your ass out of here.
Don't you go be throwing fucking sticky grenades.
Go get near me.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's this guy.
Fucking charge that shit up.
Wait, there's a tank?
There's another tank somewhere.
Okay, where is that tank?
Where is that tank?
I literally saw...
Oh my god, it's fine.
I can overcome this rock.
It's fine.
I shall overcome my adversaries.
Oh my god.
Shouldn't have peaked?
Damn, my only weakness.
Rocks and walls.
D-culture.
Ah!
With all the marine forces in this area.
Oh, it's alright.
It's just a very slow drop.
Oh, hey, I made it.
Oh, hey, look at that.
Hey, guys.
Oh my gosh, Sergeant Johnson, you're alive!
Dropship, commonly dropship inbound.
Sergeant Johnson, you did it!
I knew you would live.
Never doubted you for a second.
Okay, let me...
He can drive up this area real fast.
Don't worry.
I told you guys.
He was just taking a nap, guys.
He was just napping.
Oh my god.
Guys, I need you guys to not, like, walk around me.
Guys, please!
Okay.
They always come in pairs.
Guys, you guys got this right.
That's
not on me!
That was not on me, guys.
You cannot blame this on me.
How is that my fault?
Whatever happens, how is that my fault?
Guys.
What did I do wrong?
Oh my god.
Turn your back on me right now.
There's more where that came from.
Hey, nice shot.
Here we go.
There we go.
There, see?
They're all still alive.
But they're all...
I'm the streamer that you just want to fix.
I'm the...
You can fix your experience.
Alright.
Let's grab this real quick.
I should have...
Oh, wait.
Camouflage.
Oh, man.
What do I need that for?
No!
My tank!
Let it blow up the structure!
No!
All I know is tank!
Okay.
That's fine.
I don't think he knew I was there.
I think he got confused.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm going back.
Wait.
There's health?
Alright, guys.
There was always three of you, right?
Oh, there is health.
Nice.
There was always three of you.
That's what we're gonna...
That's gonna...
That's gonna be what we write on our report back.
Okay, guys?
That there was always three of you.
When we write our report.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Where am I getting shot?
Oh, my God.
Here.
There was always two of you.
That's what we're gonna write our report.
There was always one of you.
There's a rocket launcher here?
Where, where?
I don't see no rocket launcher.
Oh, fuck it.
It's fine.
We don't need it.
We're strong, independent John Halos.
What the fuck?
Okay, maybe I should have got a rocket launcher.
It's very annoying.
Oh, hey.
There's two of you guys.
Where did the second guy come from?
Where did you guys come from?
All right.
I like this tactic.
Let's just be in the open.
All right.
So there's...
On our report back.
What the fuck?
The tiny thing saved him?
Oh, I think he's gonna die.
Maybe.
Okay, that shot was sicked up.
You have to admit, that was a sick-ass shot.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Fuck.
Okay, this is bad.
Okay, this is very bad.
Okay.
It's fine.
There's a health pack right here.
My one HP.
Guys, that one HP was very crucial.
Where is he?
Yeah, I'm gonna take the ghost.
I just wanna...
Make sure you grab...
Get this fucker real quick.
Oh, god.
He's right above me, isn't he?
God damn, it's blocking me!
Oh, my god.
I hear him.
I hear him, too.
That's the worst part.
What?
That was a shot right there!
Oh, my god.
Okay.
Okay, he's drunk, guys.
He's drunk, guys.
Oh, my god.
Alright, somebody was partying...
Right there.
There we go.
That man was fucking drunk, lying.
Don't...
Don't drink and drive, chat.
There we go.
God damn, that got pissed me off.
Okay, my ghost now.
Alright, nice.
Okay, will this hit anything?
Okay, it hit something.
Thank God.
That doesn't mean to reload.
Oh, it doesn't mean to reload.
Wait, that's convenient.
Nice.
Alright.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Oh, there's a boost?
How do I boost?
Oh, that's not the boost.
Oh.
Okay, bring the game down.
Oh, is it too loud?
Alright.
Ah, shit!
Oh, please tell me.
I'm okay.
Oh, no boosts didn't evolve.
Okay.
Alright, we're still fine.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
I don't have my tank now, so I'm angry.
Okay.
Maybe it's this way?
I mean, it's red, though.
Alright.
Was the sound too loud earlier?
Where do I go?
Oh, it has to be here.
Yeah.
Open.
There you go.
Yay!
I'm bringing this here with me.
It's okay.
Just a flexible.
You think I care that you guys were sleeping?
That's right.
Bring this car with me.
Please, can you guys be in range of my car, though?
Now this is...
Hey, yo.
Alright, I gotta fit this through.
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
Guys, I got...
It's a little tight.
Give me a sec.
I almost got it through.
Don't worry.
You think you can just go through tight spaces and avoid me?
That's fucking right.
Can't afford this.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Wait, actually.
Wait, does this fit?
Give me a sec.
I can't fit in.
That's right.
I got...
Okay, that almost killed me, but that's fine.
That's fine.
I made it.
That actually almost killed me.
He's gonna death star me again.
Wait.
Is it gonna explode?
No, it's fine, see?
Look at that, it's fine.
It's fine.
I gotta fuck this one guy in particular.
I can't be bothered with him.
See, it's just... Look, guys.
Watch this.
See, look.
It's okay.
I put like seven bullets in there.
Go on.
No, it's okay.
I just... Wait, what?
Okay, let me check.
Okay, I'll check the HP.
Yeah, see?
Look at that.
We're so healthy.
It's just two bars.
It's fine.
Two bars.
That's more to end up.
Okay, it's one bar.
Let me... Never mind.
Now it's one bar.
I think I have to be concerned now.
Never mind.
Get out of here.
Pew, pew.
Oh, I can't be bothered with these guys.
There's way too many.
There you go.
Yeah, right here.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, we gotta go this way because there's an arrow.
I wanna see if there's anything extra.
Wait, what?
Oh, you're a brave little guy, aren't you?
You were a brave little guy.
Bum, ba-dum, bum, ba-dum, bum.
Alright.
Get pistol whipped.
Oh.
Oh yeah, this level is long.
You try.
I want him to feel a little brave, you know?
At least show the grunts.
Guys, I don't even...
AHHHHH!
Oh, this is that again.
Anyway, guys, I don't even show the Marines.
Respect if they have a sniper ammo.
I do respect the Marines, guys.
Thank you for your service.
But if you have a sniper ammo that I need...
I'm sorry.
I choose me.
Jesus Christ.
He like went everywhere, but like show me his head.
That's actually crazy.
Like he...
Oh my God, that's it.
I can't be bothered.
I can't be bothered with this fucker.
I think it's like...
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
Alright.
Okay.
Get over here.
What do you mean they're everywhere?
It's just me!
It's just John Halo.
Get over here.
I'm wasting my ammo.
Alright.
Wait, there's still one more.
Oh, you think I'm gonna leave you?
You think I'm gonna leave you so you go back to your wife and kids?
Get back over here.
What's your wife's name?
Oh shit!
Oh my God.
There we go.
I think that was the wife.
There's the wipe.
I think... Oh my god, I think that was the wipe, guys.
Whoa!
You go there, buddy.
Oh my god, respect.
Fuck you, respect, man.
Oh my god, wait, he's gone!
I... I just realized... I just realized he was gone!
I was like, wow, that guy's taking so much ammo.
It took me too long to realize.
I was like, wow, man.
Why does it take so long to die?
Oh, fuck it.
Can't be bothered.
Oh shit, okay, maybe I should bother.
What the fuck hit me there?
Holy shit, I took so much damage there.
Haha, that's looking right.
Haha, oh my god.
That's right.
Get out of here.
We only have ten bullets left.
Fuck, okay.
We gotta fly in.
We need to find some ammo.
We need to find some dead marines.
God, I should have kept some marines with me.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
It should...
Fuck.
So then I could have taken some of the ammo later.
Is it here?
It's here.
There's the arrows.
Yeah.
I passed a dead marine?
Ooh.
Free ammo.
Where's the dead marine?
Where are they?
Where are my ammo boxes?
Near elevator?
Oh my god.
This is gonna be hard to find.
Ha ha ha ha.
Oh, here.
Okay.
For my...
Oh shit.
Ooh.
Ha ha ha ha.
That sounds...
Very...
Uh...
Wait, no.
No more?
That's it?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's a pier.
Okay, nice.
Sounds so squishy.
At least I killed them together.
Oh, they're holding hands!
He's like...
I...
I tried.
The death do his part.
Alright.
Nice.
Let's see.
Let's go...
Together even.
See, look at that.
I made sure they died together.
John is a very popular name.
Okay?
On this planet.
It's like how...
A lot of people are named like...
Jesus.
Alright, let's get rid of them.
Oh shit!
Alright.
Alright, what is it?
I know it's like not pronounced Jesus, but it's spelled...
I mean, it's...
It's like...
Spelled like Jesus.
Alright, let's get out here.
Back in there...
Back on Nerd Planet, John was a fucking hero.
So every baby was named after John.
Jesus?
Yeah, Jesus.
Yeah.
I'm gonna punch that guy.
God, I hate when...
I hate that it scopes out.
Whenever...
I hate that it scopes out, though.
Oh fuck!
What the fuck?!
What hit me?!
Oh, nice.
This is bulletproof.
I don't like it when it scopes out.
If I get shot at.
There we go.
There's one more.
Oh, what?!
He fucking...
Okay, that was supposed to be a hit.
He moved his head at the last second, guys.
Aw, I wish there was like...
What is it called?
When sniper bullets pass through people.
I wish it does that.
That would be so cool.
Like a creeper shot.
Or...
Or not.
Pierce?
Yeah.
When it goes through people.
Wait, it does?
Collateral!
Yeah, I wish there was collateral.
Wait, is there collateral?
Wait, it does?!
Oh...
Oh, then it's...
It's just a skill issue, I guess.
Alright, you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm tired of these guys.
Yeah, look at it.
I like how he's like...
What the fuck was that?
There we go.
Just waiting for him to pop his head out.
What's that?
What's that blue thing that's coming towards me?
Huh.
I wonder what that could be.
Surely it's not dangerous or anything.
Eh.
Fuck this.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Get your ass over here!
Get over here!
I'm faster than you!
No!
Here.
Bro is just chillin'.
Think you can run?
No witnesses!
Alright.
Nice.
I don't know how I killed him.
I have to be sure.
Hello?
Oh.
There's something over here.
I don't see him though.
Ooh.
It's sounding scary.
I hear heavy breathing.
Can't be me.
I'm John Halo.
I don't like how there's heavy breathing.
It's a little spooky.
Okay.
So...
Oh nice.
Okay.
I don't have a lot of ammo left on this anyway.
Nice.
I have a rocket launcher now.
Alright.
That it?
That was easy.
Alright.
Oh shit.
That was worth it.
The sniper was max ammo?
Yeah, but I feel like...
I feel like...
I feel like rocker launcher time.
Is it actually better?
I don't know.
Maybe I'll just use it for...
Alright.
I'll use it.
I don't know.
I feel like...
I feel boom boom time.
I wanna boom boom.
It's boom boom time.
No, we keep the pistol.
The pistol is so good.
Okay.
That was a little...
Stupid for him.
Alright.
It's boom boom time.
Hello, aliens.
I'm here.
What the fuck?
He just ran away from the rocket?
Okay.
I don't feel like boom boom time.
Bro, that guy just dodged the entire rocket.
Okay.
He can't dodge that though.
You know what?
Fuck this.
That shit hit, right?
God damn it.
Boom boom time.
That.
You know what?
I'm gonna use the entire ammo.
So, and then I'll grab.
Are you serious?
That the...
Ricochet?
Okay.
That's bullshit.
I'm gonna use my entire one.
Okay.
Oh shit.
I said press tab.
Oh, that was pretty cool.
One more shot.
Get over here.
Oh shit!
He shot!
He fucking made it back!
Oh no.
I fucked up.
My heals.
Don't worry.
I'm going back for my sniper.
Don't worry guys.
I'll be right back.
Pause the fight.
Wait.
Oh shit.
Wait, where's my pistol?
Thank God.
Okay, there it is.
Oh shit.
There we go.
I was trying to swap this gun.
Alright.
Pause.
Pause guys.
Parley.
Nice.
Alright.
Sniper rifle time.
Time out guys.
We each get like one five minute time out.
The coach called a time out guys.
Hahaha.
Alright.
Reload this.
It's fine.
I no longer feel like it's boom boom time.
Yeah.
I've had my...
I have my fill.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
Okay, if I knew he was just going to show his head like that.
I knew that earlier.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
That shield.
Save that man's life.
Come on.
Wait, are you dead?
Oh, he's dead.
Alright.
Up I go.
Ah!
He fucking baited me!
Haha.
He's like...
Right behind you.
Hell yeah.
Jesus Christ.
How many shots?
Okay, he's dead.
I was gonna be like, Jesus Christ.
That guy live forever.
Okay, I thought that was the head.
Right?
That's good.
Get out of here.
I'm mad now.
Hahaha.
Get over here.
I recharge my shield so I can melee you.
Get out!
I know there's one more.
Where you hiding?
Hahaha.
Where are you little guy?
Molo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Do not fire in backgrounds and atmosphere.
Where are you?
What?
Did you die?
Oh, I think he's dead.
I actually don't know where he went.
Oh, he sits still.
I can't see people when you're standing still.
Alright.
Oh!
I'm outside again.
Hello?
Okay.
I didn't think they would.
I should hit them.
Okay.
I guess not.
Okay, guys.
Calm down.
Calm down, guys.
Where's the...
Where's the boss?
Where's the main guy?
Oh, he...
Oh, he went backwards?
There we go.
Okay.
We're gonna have to shoot this guy's back.
Jesus Christ, that was close.
Can he shoot himself?
Did he die?
Wait.
Oh, no.
He's okay.
Okay.
I was gonna say.
What happened to him?
It's fine.
It's the other bridge you passed.
The wall.
It's not fair.
They're camping me.
Oh, that's a window right here.
What the fuck are you doing?
It's not fair.
They're camping.
Oh, my God.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, wait.
Nice.
There we go.
Turn your back.
Get back shotted.
You made a fatal mistake, buddy.
That's fucking right.
Okay, maybe he'll, like, turn around here.
Okay.
That's good.
Okay, he's gonna turn around because he wants to shoot me here.
And then when he turns around, I'll see him.
Okay, not yet.
Not yet.
He'll turn around eventually, guys.
Okay.
Guys, I swear to God.
He'll turn around eventually.
Come on.
No hunter left behind.
Oh, my God.
Now you...
Maybe one.
He'll do it.
I swear to God, guys.
He's gonna do it.
Guys, I swear to God.
He'll do it.
He'll do it eventually, guys.
I have enough ammo.
Oh, my God.
The reload!
Of fucking course.
Of course.
He doesn't want to reload.
This fucker.
Oh, fuck yeah.
I can't.
I have enough ammo.
Again!
Oh, my God.
He keeps doing it when I'm reloading.
I got time so hard.
Okay.
What's that?
All right.
We gotta get rid of the big boy first.
Nice.
He knows he has the advantage.
Okay.
We're guys.
What the fuck are you doing?
Wait, that's not your head.
Oh!
It's fine.
He's dead.
Oh, my God.
I hit a head shot there.
That's right.
You saw that, didn't you?
Intentional head shot.
If I scream louder, I get more accurate.
With my aim.
I think I realized that.
The louder I scream, the more accurate my shots get.
Oh, fuck this guy.
His shots barely do anything.
I'm not wasting ammo.
Get over here.
Get out of here.
I have enough shield for this.
Get your ass over here.
Get over here.
Okay.
All right.
There we go.
I have enough shield.
Help me!
Nobody's gonna help you.
It's the Olympic time.
Holy shit.
His final cry was to his friend.
He looked at his friend and was like, Please help me!
No one's gonna help you.
Welcome to the real world.
Oh shit!
All right.
Okay, they're not scary.
When- When it's just like him by himself.
He literally just by himself.
And I'm like, oh hey there.
Yeah, alright, bro!
That's right.
That's right!
When you're try to be stealthy.
Don't F si** announce that you're next to me!
Before you take the shot!
Do not blow your cover before you fucking ambush them.
Stupid.
Wait, there's people above me.
Did you see me?
Oh, no.
Oh, shit.
I think you saw me, guys.
Guys, I think you saw me.
Okay, wait.
I'm at you.
Guys, I am John Halo.
Watch this.
Guys, don't watch this anymore.
Stop.
Stop watching.
Please.
Oh, my God.
I don't know if I... I don't know if I can keep surviving this.
Okay.
I am John Halo.
That's me.
I did it.
Look at that.
I survived.
Oh, hey.
There's dead Marines here.
Why are there so many dead Marines here?
Okay, we need the ammo.
Oh, and the heals.
There's...
Okay.
Oh, I didn't take...
Oh, my God.
Before you died, you didn't take any sniper ammo with you?
Get out of here.
I have enough.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
I have enough shields for this.
Yeah.
I'm gonna shoot you.
Watch this.
Get over here.
Oh, my God.
I didn't expect your buddy to shoot, too.
Get out of here.
Where'd you live?
That's right.
I'm gonna shoot your ankles.
That's fucking right.
Get your ankles shot.
You got high frames.
Yeah, it's like, how the fuck...
What the fuck you live?
How did you live?
How the fuck did you live?
It's one minute.
Oh, my God.
These guys live through by one minute.
Yeah, he tanked that.
Oh, the red one is double HP.
Okay.
Gotta make sure he doesn't take that shit.
That shit.
Oh, my head.
Stupid.
Oh, no.
Not him.
Do we always charge the shield?
Let me get rid of this guy first.
I don't trust myself to run across.
Okay, now I run.
Now I run.
Now I'm booking it.
Go, Doki.
Go.
What the fuck?
How do I drive this?
Oh, shit.
Wait, it's like a mini tank.
Oh, nice.
Oh, did he live?
How did he live?
Get over here.
There we go.
Oh, shit!
Oh!
Resistance appears to be increasing.
It must be close to the control center.
Okay.
I do this again, I guess.
Analyzing.
Oh, my God.
This sucks.
Okay.
That sucked.
Because I couldn't scope in.
Get me out of here.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm gonna wait.
Before I...
I couldn't, like, get a scope in there.
Okay.
I have to get him out here before I do anything.
Look at this guy.
Man, I should be able to get us...
There we go.
Wait, he got up?
No!
I didn't know I could fly!
Oh,
my...
Oh, that's awkward.
I didn't realize it was a plane!
It looks so different when it's on the ground!
Oh, my God.
I can't believe it.
I missed the plane!
Oh, my God.
Where's the cockpit for this?
Does this hit kill him?
Okay.
It's not...
That's not fair.
Alright.
Okay.
One more name.
Oh, my God.
That's not fair.
That's actually not fair.
I'll just kill this guy because I'm angry.
I'm sorry.
It looked like a car when it's on the ground.
It was so car-shaped.
It was just car-shaped.
God!
I didn't mess up.
Thank you.
It was a super chat.
Oh, my God.
That could have been me.
That could have been me right there.
Okay.
It looked like...
You can't say it has wings.
More...
It looked more like a penis than it did a plane.
You have to admit that.
You can't lie.
It looked like a dick with balls.
Okay.
True.
It looks like...
It looks more like a dick with balls.
And you guys know that.
It barely looked like a...
I don't know!
Oh, my God.
Please, I'm trying to...
Guys, I'm distracted.
I'm trying to fucking...
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to do this melee thing.
Okay.
That works, too.
I'll take that.
Oh, my God.
Of course, that's fucking...
There we go.
We take those.
We fucking take those.
Okay.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
Alright, it's melee time.
They're little babies.
I'm gonna kill this guy in his sleep.
So he'll...
It's good!
He died in his sleep.
It's like he never suffered.
Okay.
I need to...
Shoot you.
So I can melee you.
Get out of here.
What the fuck hit me?
Oh, my God.
He brought his dad!
His dad's here.
He got his older brother.
Okay.
You're too far in melee.
Oh, wait.
No, that's just his older brother.
No, I can kill him, too.
I'll get rid of your older brother.
Bleeding the family line.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Okay.
The family flank.
Oh, no.
Fuck.
Okay.
I got too cocky.
They're working together.
My HP.
That's it.
I'm taking high ground.
Get over here.
You thought I couldn't get to high ground?
You know I'm serious when I parkour.
Okay.
Here we go.
Is there...
Is there like any...
Oh my god.
Is there...
Get Ohana.
Is there any dead marines?
Anywhere?
Any dead marines that could spare me some heathens?
Oh, no.
No dead marines.
Alright.
Holy shit.
This level is long.
In two hours, I'm still here.
This is a giant...
Oh, I'm going down.
We play legendary mode with crowd control on.
I think people would really like that.
Imposter snake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, I don't even think I'll beat the game.
Oh, hey.
Wait, what?
What is he doing?
Just standing there.
Like, this guy was just at...
What a boring day at work.
Alright, nothing ever happens here.
Okay, I thought this...
I thought it was bulletproof.
The one time the windows are not bulletproof?
I was like, they're so stupid.
Try to shoot me through a bulletproof window.
There you go.
Get over here.
Oh my god.
He's trying to do a little circle.
Get over here.
You're just a waste of ammo.
Get out of here.
Any dead Marines?
Oh, thank god.
Thank god Marines died here.
Alright.
Let's get down.
That's what he would thought.
Alright.
Everybody's dead.
Nice.
Another family killed.
Let's go.
A dead...
The only good alien is a dead alien.
I'm a lost, though.
I'm a lost.
Uh...
Here I go.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Oh, this is where...
No, this is the other side.
Damn right.
That's right.
Military propaganda is working on me.
That's when you know it works.
Maybe it's this way.
I just ran past it.
I'm so confused.
Bro!
They didn't make signs.
How do the other aliens not get lost?
They're so stupid.
Oh, there's the side.
Never mind.
Wait.
Where the fuck?
Okay.
I'll follow this arrow.
Oh, there it is.
It's glowing.
There it is.
Oh, these are the sides.
Alright.
Hello.
The entrance to the control center is located at the top of the pyramid.
Let's get up.
We should commandeer one of those ghosts.
We're going to need the firepower.
Yoink.
Oh, shit!
That's a tank!
Bye.
I mean, do I have to fight all these guys?
No, right?
Wait.
Can I even destroy the tank?
You destroy it with regular bullets?
I don't know.
Not really?
Okay.
I'll just go over here then.
Hey, guys.
Can't get me.
What you gonna do?
Nothing.
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'll recharge.
Where's, like, going past?
Jesus Christ.
You're so tanky.
I forgot how tanky you are, like, outside of shooting my pistol.
That's fine.
There we go.
He tripped and fell.
Okay.
Now I'm just gonna...
Aw.
He's like...
Barry, you okay?
Yeah.
I don't think he's gonna shoot back right here.
Honestly.
Whoops.
Sorry.
This is an embarrassing...
Oh!
What happened to timeout?
God.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
He missed.
So stupid.
Okay.
Maybe...
Wait.
I can splatter him?
That was a mistake.
Oh!
My car!
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
There we go.
That's okay.
I don't need my car.
How do I get up top here?
Oh, it's this way.
No, there's no boost in combat evolved.
Yes.
They said there wasn't.
So I believe them.
Okay.
I can dodge that.
Wait.
Is that Banshee...
No.
That Banshee's broken.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah.
There's no...
Is that Banshee broken?
Look.
Yeah.
See?
I'm pretty sure that looks like a...
Oh, wait.
No.
That one isn't.
Wait.
No.
That's just the wall.
Yeah.
I'm gonna say it.
Like...
I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure it's like...
There's like explosive marks and everything.
Like...
It looks very, very dead.
I don't know.
I don't...
Oh, it is.
Okay.
Oh, it's...
Oh, no.
Oh, my God.
It's so hard to drive these.
Alright.
That's fine.
Oh, my God.
This is fine.
This is not fine.
Okay.
I'm okay.
My ghost is maybe not okay.
But I'm okay.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Please turn around.
Okay.
I don't think my ghost is okay anymore.
Wait.
You live?
Oh, wait.
It's still...
Okay.
I don't trust...
I don't think I should.
Legally, I think it might explode.
I'm pretty sure it's gonna explode if I try to do anything.
Holy shit.
You have too much HP.
Someone needs to put you down.
And that person is me.
All right.
Hello, hello, everybody.
It's okay.
Why the fuck did he...
Oh, he's like, hey.
All right.
What?
That literally passed through him.
Oh, no.
Where's the second guy?
Where's his buddy?
I know you come in pairs.
Oh, what?
No!
There's the second guy!
There he is!
I got baited again!
The world record for this level on Legendary is 3 minutes and 20...
Oh, my.
They give us a super chat.
That's crazy.
Distraction.
I don't need the turret.
All I need is one shot.
That's all I need.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
But I also need them to turn their backs on me.
Come on.
Are you serious?
Oh, my God.
But, like...
Not now, though.
Come on.
Turn your backs on me.
Reposition yourself.
God damn it.
Okay.
Reposition yourself, like, now.
There we go.
That works.
I shot him in the side.
Oh, no.
I'm so bad at, like, dodging those.
Oh!
God damn it!
God damn it, I'm so...
No!
No, don't tell me I...
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Which way?
Not me!
Okay, you did it again.
I...
Oh, my...
Okay, I didn't think he was gonna do that.
Okay?
To be fair.
Just shoot him on the legs.
Okay, when I say reposition himself, I meant him.
I meant him, not me.
He should come out soon.
Okay, maybe he'll let...
Show yourself.
Where's the second guy?
Okay, that works.
That works.
Thank God.
Alright, one by one, everybody.
One by one.
Single file.
Okay, you think he sees me?
Okay, I think from that glowing green light...
He saw me.
There you go.
That was...
That run...
Was a lot better.
Smell, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The world record has three minutes because there's a trick where you can get a banshee...
Which disciples all spawns?
Wait, then just fucking...
Flies to the end goal?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, that's crazy.
Oh, what's that?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I see him.
It's okay.
I don't think he sees me.
Okay.
It's fine.
It's okay.
I have more nades.
I don't know where it's gonna go, but I'll hit something.
I got your legs.
I got...
Legs stuck.
Fucking stupid.
The easiest shot of my life.
Oh, he's stuck.
Upset bro, I'm stuck.
Wait, what?
Yeah, we'll grab the little guys first.
Little guys are annoying.
I think he's dead.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
I'm your nades.
Over I go.
Up, step chief.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha.
Word, word, word.
Time to sell.
Yeah.
Nice.
Alright.
Open?
Open.
Oh, I don't like that.
Why is it so empty?
Okay.
For real?
Kurtana?
Kurtana, you're not lying?
Can I kill everybody?
Oh?
Hello, it's I.
John Halo!
This is it.
Halo's control center.
Surely it won't be an ambush or anything.
Other guys are Grunts, Sword Boy, Racer, Elite Shield Bros, or Jackals?
Doki... Doki Bird is a beaut.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you, Omni.
I feel like I'll be ambushed or something.
You alright?
Hey, Kurtana!
Oh my god.
She looked like that before?
They definitely made her hotter in the mor- in the mor- Every sequel, they make it hotter.
This ring isn't a cudgel, you barbarian.
It's something else.
Something much more important.
The covenant, we're right.
This ring, it's Forerunner.
Give me a second to access.
Yes, the Forerunner built this place, what they called a fortress world, in order to- What?
What?
No, that can't be.
What is it, Kurtana?
Oh, those covenant fools.
They must have known.
There must have been signs.
Slow down.
You're losing me.
Yeah, you're losing me too.
The covenant found something.
Buried in this ring.
Something horrible.
And now, they're afraid.
Something buried?
Where?
Captain, we've got to stop the captain.
Wait, what?
Why?
The weapons cache he's looking for.
It's not really- We can't let him get inside.
Wait, why?
I don't understand.
There's no time.
Get out of here.
Find keys.
Stop him.
Wait, what?
He said it's too late.
Kurtana, please!
What do you mean there's no time to explain?
Kurtana!
Why won't you tell me?
Oh no, I'm in the swamp now.
Okay, so we have to stop keys.
What did he do?
Why do you have to stop keys?
Well, enough alone.
What does enhanced graphics look like?
Jesus Christ, it's so blue.
Look at all these grass.
Alright.
Where is he?
Oh my god, a lot of them are dying though.
Get out of here.
Oh, checkpoint.
Yeah, I'm not gonna waste ammo.
I don't know where I can find other dead marines.
I hear a radio transmission over here.
Hello?
Hello, anybody here?
Oh, wait, where are the marines here?
Is this where Captain Keys was?
Oh.
Oh, Captain Keys has been captured.
Okay, so Captain Keys is here.
So...
Is shotgun around here?
I don't see no shotgun.
I'm just gonna grab the regular gun then.
I don't like normal AR.
Okay, so Captain Keys is...
Is captured right now.
So we gotta find him.
No shotgun?
Sad.
Because I guess it's too easy!
Pussy!
Oh my god.
Really fucking play behind a shield like a pussy?
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
Okay.
Where is...
Wow!
Where did I go?
Swarm level is...
It's weird.
I feel like this isn't the way.
Oh my god.
Everything is so blue.
Look at these...
Big fucking trees.
Follow the lights?
Where else would the lights go?
Here?
Oh!
I can climb up here!
I didn't realize I can climb up the tree.
Okay.
Oh, it's so spooky.
No!
Okay.
I thought I fell down and had to do this all over again.
Wait, what?
Oh, that's them!
That's my teammates!
Don't worry!
Wait, why are they coming?
Okay.
We're gonna kill these guys first.
These guys are annoying.
Get out of here.
Get out of here!
Oh shit!
Okay, they haven't...
Okay, there's a lot of them.
Give me a sec.
Don't worry.
They don't know where I am too.
They're just as confused.
My best strat.
Running around a tree.
There we go.
Jesus, I shot you too!
Alright, I killed a thousand grunts.
Alright, now we go in.
Why are they running away from that area?
Alright.
Time to find out why.
Hello?
Oh?
Captain Keys?
Oh, the elevator came back up.
Alright.
Down I go.
Word, word.
Word, word, word.
They were running away from here.
What the fuck's going on?
Okay, I didn't realize they were...
They were all there.
Alright, get out of here.
You think you could...
Use this as a barrier?
Whole gang's here.
Just in case.
I don't know what's over here.
I heard like...
Alright.
Ooh.
Okay, let me recharge my shield a little.
Whoa!
I said let me recharge my shield a little!
Time out!
Alright.
Okay, now we can play.
With this.
I hit him?
Haha, no shield for you.
Hello?
Actually, let's grab these.
Do this real quick.
Alright.
Down I go!
I don't know if I want to go down though.
Wait, I hear something below me.
Oh no, that's just my footsteps.
Hahaha!
I just heard myself.
I'm tired of you.
Wait, I was gonna say that.
I can't.
There's no way that breaks my legs.
There you go.
Must be here.
Cause they're all guarding this one door.
Hahaha!
Not being a good guard, so.
What?!
Okay, that phased through!
There's no way!
That shit actually phased through!
That's bullshit!
That's actually bullshit!
Fuck this.
Get it.
Alright.
That's fucking right.
No more shield for you.
Word wart.
Wait, what?
What is that?
Huh?
What's that green thing?
Whoa!
Bye.
Oh.
I didn't kill these guys.
What the fuck?
What happened here?
I didn't kill them.
What the fuck?
Wait, it's the green thing again.
Huh.
Oh.
What's going on?
I fell in.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What, what, what?
Hello?
Hey, it's me!
What?
I'll blow your brains out!
You freaks!
I won't be like you!
I'll die first!
Dead!
That's what I did!
Played dead!
They took the live ones!
Oh god, I can still hear them!
Monsters!
Are the monsters in the room here with us right now?
Just leave!
No, they're just sleeping!
You're gone!
Get it!
Go on!
Sergeant always comes back!
They won't get me!
Oh god!
I don't wanna be like them, please!
Please no!
What the fuck?
Are you okay?
Alright...
Alright, I was not joking!
It had to be done!
Guys, he's just sleeping, I just...
Oh, wait what?
Oh, there's that chamber again!
Okay, something happened in this chamber!
Something happened there.
Alright, things are turning.
Guys, there's no way Captain Keyes is a bad guy.
He's the captain.
Good soldiers follow orders, guys.
There's no way.
He would never betray us like this.
Hold on.
She figured out the twin.
Okay, guys, that twin.
The fact that Captain Keyes is a bad guy.
Cortana was like, we gotta stop Captain Keyes.
Yeah, no fucking shit.
He's a bad guy.
What would what?
How did you know, Donkey?
God damn it.
I can't believe Cortana spoiled it for everybody.
She is chat.
Oh?
Oh, he's alive.
He's just sleeping with his eyes open, right?
It's nappy time.
Jenkins?
What?
Bill, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Somehow Palpatine returned.
Why do we always have to listen to this old stuff, Sarge?
Watch your mouth, son.
This stuff is your history.
It should remind you grunts what we're fighting to protect.
And see, he's back!
If the Covenant wanna wipe out this particular part of my history, that's fine by me.
Yeah, better it than us.
You ask him real nice next time you see him, Vicente.
I'm sure they'll be happy to oblige.
LZ looks clear.
Go, go, go!
There is music, but it's super quiet.
But all the mixing, the audio is combined into one fucking setting.
Stay close, Jenkins!
Mendoza, move it up!
Wait here for the captain and his squad, then get your ass inside.
Sir!
Sergeant Johnson, my king!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Forward?
He's like, I'm bored now.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Which is weird, right?
I mean, look at it!
What's that?
Scramble the insides?
But it's like a chestburster.
What's that?
Plasma scoring?
Yeah, I don't know.
Maybe there was an accident, you know?
Friendly fire...
ADHD.
Skip to the good part.
What do we have, Sergeant?
Looks like a Covenant patrol.
Badass elite units.
All KIA.
Real pretty!
Friend of yours?
Now, we just met.
Ha ha ha ha!
Skip intro.
Right, well, let's get this door open.
I'll try, sir.
But it looks like these Covenant work pretty hard to lock it down.
Just do it, son.
Yes, sir.
Skippa, skippa!
Was that easy?
Holy shit!
I mean, why is it so empty?
What's going on, soldier?
Covenant?
What are they?
I thought Halo was all about fighting the Covenant.
In the squad's position and find out what the hell is going on.
But...
I don't have time for your lift, soldier.
I gave you an order.
What?
Oh, it's the green stuff!
Where's that coming from, Mendoza?
I don't...
There!
Mira!
Mira?
The fuck is that?
Yeah, that's the green stuff!
Hold still!
Let him have it!
Oh my god, it's like aliens!
Sergeant, we're surrounded!
Goddammit, Jenkins!
Fire your weapon!
There are too many, Sarge!
Don't even think about it!
Who the fuck just brings only a...
Oh, it's Captain Keys.
Okay.
Oh, this is loco!
This is loco!
Oh!
Wait, that's it?
The recording stops there?
The flood.
Oh?
Hold on.
Wouldn't it be funny if I just break that glass and we fall down?
They just...
Die?
Oh, there's all their guns.
Oh!
Wait, there they are!
Okay, that is a lot of them.
Okay.
I'm just gonna charge this up, actually.
It might actually be easier.
Now, I can take them.
They're not that many, anyway.
Look at that.
See?
It's not that bad.
Where did them go?
Wait.
Okay, I ran out of ammo.
Oh, shit!
Guys!
I can't take them!
I lied!
Ah!
Fuck!
Wait.
Where's...
Okay, I need the AR.
I need the AR.
I need the...
That's fine.
Okay.
That's a dead end.
Maybe this is not a dead end.
That's also a...
Where the fuck do I go?
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
Fuck this.
Wait.
I can take this, actually.
Wait a minute.
Wait.
This works.
I can take this.
Look at that.
See?
Boom.
Oh, shit.
Never...
Boom.
There you go.
That's so bad, actually.
Let me just...
Let me just do that, actually.
See?
Okay.
How the fuck did my team die to this?
It's literally one melee hit.
Oh, wait.
I'm a super soldier.
Nevermind.
I forgot.
They're just...
Regular people.
Look at that.
It's like popping a balloon.
That's so easy.
Just popping a little balloon.
Nobody said not...
Nobody told them to...
What the fuck?
They all just like ambushed me.
They're like, yes.
She'll eventually come inside.
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
Wait.
Oh, shit!
Is that them?
Is that my team?
Okay.
I think they're dead.
Alright.
Okay.
They're not that strong.
Thank god.
I think that was them.
I think that was the squad.
Holy shit.
So, okay.
Oh, okay.
They just smacked me.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that was them.
Oh, no.
Where do I go?
They don't carry nades.
Oh, my god!
Oh, god.
Oh, why did I use up all my nades?
Oh!
They're so...
Oh, wait.
Nice.
They do carry nades.
Okay.
Oh, god.
These guys are dangerous.
These guys are so dangerous.
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
How is there so many of them?!
Oh.
Oh, I don't know where to go.
I don't know where to go.
I just saw them all fucking bunched up.
So, I assume it's the right direction!
What the fuck?
Oh, it's right here.
It's right here.
I thought I went the right way because there were so many bodies there.
Oh.
Did I just leave?
I think I'm just supposed to leave.
Oh, my god.
He just smashed me!
Oh!
Oh, my god!
Fuck!
Okay.
Okay, they die faster with pistol.
That's good to know.
It's okay.
I found it.
Okay.
There you go.
I think I'm going the right way.
I don't know.
I'm a little lost.
You got this, Covenant!
You guys got this!
I believe in you!
I'm trying to...
Guys, where...
Where am I?
Please, SHUT THEM!
Where's this door?
Where...
Where are the doors?
I feel like I've been going around!
And around!
Oh, my god.
There's the craze.
Okay, there it is.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
I can't get up from that.
These crates do not let me go up.
Okay, I came from here.
Is this crate?
Oh, my god.
It's this way.
Hey, guys.
Thanks for saving me back there.
But...
I need to get...
I need to get out of here.
Sorry, buddy.
But I need to get out of here.
Alright.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Oh, I should've...
Oh, it's okay.
I need the app.
It's fine.
I'll use this for now.
If I kill more...
More of the covenant.
I'll grab the...
Plasma gun.
Oh, I hear them.
Oh!
Oh, I knew it.
My flashlight!
Oh, I knew it!
Where's your gun?
Oh, my god!
What the fuck did you do?
Did you fucking eat their guns?
Oh, my god.
Oh, my...
Okay.
What the fuck?
What the fuck they have guns?!
What the fuck?!
Oh, they can just...
God!
Holy shit!
Oh, my god!
Who the fuck gave them guns?!
My HP!
Oh, my god!
My poor HP!
I didn't expect them to have guns!
Holy shit!
God!
Oh, he's just chillin'.
He's just chillin' over there.
Oh, my god.
Please.
Please, I need your plasma gun.
Okay.
Wait, there's a shotgun?!
Where's the shotgun?!
Oh, my god!
There it is!
Oh, thank god!
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
I can't believe they have guns now.
Who the fuck taught these zombies how to fucking shoot their guns?!
Oh, thank god.
Oh, no.
Okay.
We're okay.
We got to there.
A zombie is supposed to have no brain development!
Alright.
We're okay.
Okay.
We're fine.
We don't know how to jump.
Oh, no.
I think it's this way.
Oh, I think it's...
Get out of here!
That's right!
Cat chest versus me!
Oh, my god.
That's right!
I have armor!
What you gonna do about that, bitch?!
I'm so lost.
I'm so lost!
It's down here.
Oh, my god.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
It's...
Holy shit!
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm so not healthy right now.
I am not healthy at all.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is so fine.
Okay.
Okay, the most bullshit part is that I can't steal their guns.
I think that's the bullshit.
I know you're behind me.
I knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I have ears.
I knew it.
I still have ears.
God, I don't know if I should take that.
Jesus, it takes so many shots.
Where do I go from here?
Okay, it's up top.
It's up top.
How do I get up top?
Oh my God, it's up top.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Most importantly, they are bottom eaters.
Thank God the shotgun's one shot.
It's okay.
I just gotta get to the other side.
And then we should be good.
I thought there would be an elevator there.
My bad.
Guess I should not have dropped out.
Oh my God.
How do I get back up top?
Do I have to do this all over again?
Oh my God.
I thought dropping down was the answer.
Okay, here we go again.
It's okay.
I figured it out this time.
Okay, we can do this again.
I wanna get to the other side.
What the fuck?
How do I get to the other side?
Oh wait.
There's a button.
I keep forgetting these are buttons.
There we go.
I don't know why I keep forgetting that.
Alright, eventually, like...
It'll stop, right?
Eventually, the horde will stop, right?
Oh my God.
There's the other elevator.
Oh, thank God.
Please go up.
Please.
Oh, thank God it goes up.
I can't believe it.
When did this game became a zombie game?
Where's Captain Keys?
It's me.
Don't worry, men.
I'll never forget your first blood.
I thought it was just Halo and Covenant.
Why have I never heard about fucking zombies?
In my Halo game?
I've never heard...
It's like the most well-kept secret for like all beginners.
I swear, I've never heard about the zombies.
In Halo.
They gave us a super chat.
This is literally the first time I've ever...
WOOOOO!
I'm on.
Oh no.
Spy.
Go forward!
You guys got this!
Just go forward!
Just keep going forward!
Alright.
Come on Marines!
Okay, you're just shooting at each other.
What?
Like, what are you guys shoot- Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah.
That's what you're shooting at.
I was gonna say, like, what the fuck are you guys shooting at?
Oh, there's a lot.
There's a lot of them.
Guys, stop shooting me!
Stop!
Guys!
Oh my god, they're all dead.
They're all dead.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're all dead.
Okay.
That's on them.
I did everything I could to save my team.
I actually did everything I could.
That's on them.
That's not me.
It's not my fault.
I shot my shots.
What's this?
Hey, I hear gunshots.
Wait, what?
Oh, hey.
Friends.
Nice.
Okay, these guys are better than the fucking marine.
Oh!
No!
Okay.
We just stay here?
Yeah, who needs humans when you have robot friends?
Oh, there we go.
Yay!
Wait!
Bob Halo?
Or is that me?
I am 343 guilty spark.
Oh, 343!
Oh, that's me!
Someone has released the phone.
That was just darker.
My function is to prevent it from leaving this installation.
But I require your assistance.
Come.
This way.
Don de esta la biblioteca.
It's very loco.
Chief!
The library.
Time for the filter.
Wait, they can come back to life?
What do you mean?
We must come up the index before we can activate the installation.
What?
What do you mean, guys?
No, no.
It's dead.
You're just seeing things, guys.
They're all dead.
Wait, why is that?
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Guys, I think I'm gonna...
You know what?
I think it's a good stopping point.
Guys, it's not that I'm getting filtered.
Tomorrow.
It's just...
I need to record something tonight.
Okay.
I need to make sure my voice is okay.
Guys.
We'll let...
We'll let future Doki finish Halo.
Until, like, next week.
Welcome to the worst level ever made.
Thank you for the super chat.
Broken file.
Thank you, thank you.
Snake, thank you for the super chat.
Moz, let's get a clip compilation of Doki's rage quit next stream.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyways, welcome to the tomato file.
Welcome, welcome.
You know what?
Yeah, we'll just...
We'll let future Doki handle this.
Anyways.
That was fun though.
I'm having a fun time with my first Halo game.
That's crazy.
I did not expect zombies to be like...
I feel like I've never seen anyone ever talk about the flood at all.
Like, whenever I've seen people mention Halo.
It's always Halo and the Covenant aliens.
I swear I've never seen anything about the aliens ever before.
So, it's actually like my first time like experiencing that.
So, it's very interesting.
I'm very surprised.
It's like such a well-kept secret.
And like nobody has like spoiled it to like anybody.
Like no one has really spoiled that part for like people who have like...
Like, I guess like baby like surface level knowledge of Halo.
And like even when I watch like you know Halo speedruns.
I feel like I never like registered that like...
Because you know like in the SDGD, QD, BC, AD.
They'll have like Halo speedruns and stuff.
And I feel like I've never seen anything about the flood.
I've always seen stuff about the Covenant and like wood, wood, wood.
But I feel like I've never seen anything about like the flood and like the aliens and stuff.
Like the zombie shit.
.
Jakchano, thank you the Superchat, thank you, thank you, thank you.
The ultimate cliffhanger.
Future Doki's gonna be angry with you when you're going to have to explain your...
Blame past Doki.
But, yeah.
This was fun.
Yeah.
I've been having a fun time.
Uh, next week, you wha superchat, thank you, thank you.
Glad you made it to the flood.
Unspoiled.
There's a lot of fun stuff to come.
Thank you prprio superchat, thank you, thank you.
Sir Lauren, thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
Alright, I'll stop here.
Literally, how little me would react to reaching these levels in the campaign.
I just play the early levels over and over.
Wait, no, it's the library that... What makes... Okay, wait, no, don't tell me.
I will find out what makes the library such a bad level.
Such a fucked up level.
Future Turkey will find out together with chat.
My next stream... The next stream will be like, the library level.
Hey, guys.
I'm going to go head off now.
I have some stuff I need to record.
And I wish I could do a little extra Zatsudon Super Chat reading after this.
But starting after my birthday next week, we're bringing back the Super Chat reading and post-game Zatsudons.
Because I'll be a lot less busy after that.
But anyway, guys.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
But if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.